[MUSIC PLAYING]
TYLER SIMKO: My research
focuses on local politics,
like the people that serve on
your school board and the city
council.
And these people have more of an
immediate impact on your life.
And I think that they
get too frequently ignored
in the literature.
My name is Tyler Simko.
I'm a senior in the
politics department
and in the Program for
Statistics and Machine
Learning.
This year during my
second term on the board,
I was elected as president
of the South Amboy
Board of Education,
which has been
a very exciting new
opportunity for me.
I'm involved in the budget,
the education, the staffing,
the policies.
I'm the one that leads
all the public meetings.
And I try to go to all
the events and the games.
It's trying to be a
face for the board
and to show them that we're not
this scary, abstract body that
makes all the decisions.
But we're there to serve
the students and the public.
JORGE DIAZ: It's an
honor not only for myself
as a superintendent to have
Tyler, who was not too long
ago a student here.
He's a product of our community
not only as a student,
but also as a valedictorian.
So I think as a community, we're
very proud of not only what
he accomplished here
as student, but what
he's accomplishing as a
student at Princeton University
and now serving in a leadership
capacity on our school board.
TYLER SIMKO: So at
every door you go to,
you'll start with the script,
you'll read it through.
But you'll only --
KOSUKE IMAI: Tyler
found very interesting
the idea of using
statistics and data
analysis to study political
problems and social science
problems.
When he run for the education
board in his hometown,
he ran the randomized
experiment on trying
to examine how different
campaign messages affect
the voters.
I hope that other students
will take from Tyler's story
that there are so
many things you
can do if you take all the
opportunities seriously
and work hard.
Through the senior thesis
and junior papers,
you can actually make
a huge difference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TYLER SIMKO: I decided to teach
through the Freshmen Scholars
Institute because I think
it's very important for places
like Princeton to
ensure that students
from all different
types of backgrounds
can succeed at Princeton.
Oh it's one's story
to have the experience
to be accepted to Princeton.
But trying to succeed
once they get here
is an entirely different story.
Programs like FSI
introduce students
to a community of
students that are going
through the same types of things
as them and can support them,
both during the program
and then afterwards.
The most important thing that
you can do for other students
is to be a mentor.
Students that come from either
first-generation backgrounds
or from schools like
ours that don't always
send kids to Princeton,
I don't think
that those students
should have to figure out
the whole process on their own.
If I can help them in some
way with my own experiences,
I will.
[MUSIC PLAYING]